tenemos aquí un conjunto de ecuaciones
paramétricas donde x
ambas están definidas en términos de t
así es que si evaluamos a estas
funciones en todos los posibles valores
de t y después los gráfica moss vamos a
obtener una curva en el plano x ahora lo
que quiero que hagamos es que
encontremos la derivada de y con
respecto a x y también la segunda
derivada de g
con respecto a x y ambas van a estar en
términos de t así es que empecemos
primero encontrando la derivada de y con
respecto a x la derivada de jake con
respecto a x es igual a y esto ya lo
hemos visto en otros vídeos esto es
igual a la derivada de g
con respecto a t entre la derivada de x
con respecto a t y bueno es
es igual a ver cuál es la derivada de
jake con respecto a t de i d t es igual
a aquí la derivada de y elevado a la 3 t
con respecto a 3 t
alatriste y luego la derivada de 3 t con
respecto a t estrés
así es que multiplicamos por 3 aunque
podríamos poner este 3 por acá y luego
la derivada de menos 1 pues no importa
como cambie t menos uno se va a quedar
exactamente igual por lo que su derivada
es cero así es que por acá la derivada
de jake con respecto a t estrés por el
elevado a la 3 t y esto lo estamos
dividiendo entre la derivada de x con
respecto a t y la derivada de x con
respecto
es igual a bueno empezamos con esta
constante y la derivada de y elevado a
la potencia 2 t con respecto a 2 t es el
ala 2 t pero luego tenemos que encontrar
la derivada de 2 t con respecto a t lo
cual es 2 así es que en total nos queda
6 x a la 2 t
por el 2t y esto a cuánto es igual ya
estamos utilizando un color un poco más
neutral por aquí tres sextos es un medio
y acá tenemos
a la tres t menos dos t y para llegar a
esto simplemente estoy utilizando las
propiedades de los exponentes pero ya
que estamos aquí sí tenemos tres test y
le quitemos dos nos queda simplemente
una t entonces esto de aquí se
simplifica y nos queda una sola t y
listo ya encontramos la derivada de jake
con respecto a x en términos de t pero
ahora como encontramos la segunda
derivada con respecto a x como
encontramos la segunda derivada de y con
respecto
a x como lo hacemos para encontrar esto
bueno te voy a dar una pista
vamos a utilizar esto mismo que tenemos
aquí si quieres encontrar la derivada de
algo con respecto a x lo que puedes
hacer es encontrar la derivada de ese
algo con respecto al tiempo y lo
dividimos entre la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo y cómo le hacemos
para encontrar esto bueno pues vamos a
derivar con respecto al tiempo a la
primera derivada de ye con respecto a x
pero lo tenemos que escribir paso por
paso así es que vamos a encontrar la
derivada con respecto al tiempo d
y esto que tenemos aquí de g de equis y
esto lo vamos a dividir entre la
derivada de x con respecto al tiempo si
por el momento no te parece claro que
aquí estamos utilizando la misma idea
que tenemos aquí ponle una pausa al
vídeo y piénsalo un poquito más y bueno
veamos que estábamos haciendo aquí aquí
estábamos buscando la derivada de y con
respecto a x y para encontrarla lo que
hicimos fue encontrar la derivada de y
con respecto al tiempo y lo dividimos
entre la derivada de x con respecto al
tiempo por acá lo que queremos es
encontrar la segunda derivada de y con
respecto a x pero a ver tal vez lo
podemos explicar un poco mejor por acá
estábamos buscando la derivada de ye con
respecto a x y para encontrarla lo que
hicimos fue encontrar la derivada de
jake con respecto al tiempo
derivada de y con respecto al tiempo y
dividirla entre la derivada de x con
respecto al tiempo pero ahora queremos
encontrar la derivada con respecto de x
pero en lugar de y de la derivada de y
con respecto a x entonces lo que tenemos
que hacer es sustituir ayer por la
derivada de ye con respecto a x siempre
que veamos una y vamos a poner la
derivada de jake con respecto a x y nos
queda así aquí tenemos la derivada con
respecto a t derivada con respecto a t
de en lugar de y ponemos la derivada de
y con respecto a x porque ok aquí
pusimos del dt pero esto es simplemente
anotación lo voy a escribir de otra
forma
es igual a la derivada con respecto a t
de g
así es que para que teníamos una y ahora
tenemos de jett de x y aquí ya nada más
nos falta poner de x de t pero bueno
regresando por acá esto puede verse como
algo muy difícil pero en realidad es muy
sencillo evaluarlo tomar la derivada con
respecto de t de la primera derivada de
jake con respecto de x es simplemente
tomar la derivada con respecto de t de
esta expresión de aquí y esto es muy
sencillo tenemos por aquí la constante
un medio por la derivada de a la t que
es simplemente
a la t y eso lo estamos dividiendo entre
la derivada de x con respecto de t que
la tenemos por acá que es
por el lado este y esto lo podemos
escribir como 1 entre 2 por 6
x
al menos 2 tb y esto lo podemos escribir
como 1 entre 12 por el ala menos t
o como uno entre 12 por el ala t y ya
terminamos